i'll be retiring from tennis and
it's the first time i've actually said
it out loud and um yeah it's hard to say
but i'm
so happy and i'm so ready and
i just know at the moment in my heart
for
me as a person this is right to be able
to win
wimbledon which was my dream my the one
true dream that i wanted in tennis um
that really changed my perspective and
i just had a i just had that gut feeling
after after wimbledon um
and had spoken to my team quite a lot
about it
and
there was just a little part of me that
wasn't quite
satisfied wasn't quite fulfilled there
was a perspective shift in me in this
second phase of my career that my
happiness wasn't dependent on the
results
and
success for me is is knowing that i've
given absolutely every everything i can
i'm fulfilled i'm happy
and
i know
how much work it takes to
to bring the best out of yourself
and
i've said it to my team
multiple times it's just i don't have
that in me anymore i don't have the
the physical drive the emotional um
want and and kind of everything it takes
to to challenge yourself at the very top
of the level anymore and i think i just
know that i'm absolutely
i i am spent um i just know physically i
have nothing more to give and
that for me is
is success i've given absolutely
everything i can um to this beautiful
sport of tennis and
i'm
really happy with that and for me that
that is my success and i know that
people may not understand it and that's
okay i'm okay with that um because i
know that for me
um
[Music]
body the person has so many dreams that
she wants to chase after um that don't
necessarily involve
traveling the world being away from my
family being away from my home which is
where i've always wanted to be it's
where i've grown up and i'll never ever
ever stop loving tennis
it'll always be a massive part of my
life but now i think it's important that
i get to enjoy
the next phase of my life as as ashby
the person not not ash by the athlete